This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证真人。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行在其他任何地方都觉得不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执业专业人士交流。有多少人身披铠甲。这向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须这么做，请收听
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控让人生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测结果。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱之陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he does. He's going to get what he
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神韧性、健身以及建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他做的。他会得到他
deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we're going to talk about a topic that I don't think is spoken about nearly enough, particularly amongst those in our 20s, or really at any age, despite it being so much more common than I think we recognize. and that is health anxiety, the fear or preoccupation with the belief that we are currently
应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《相信闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理学。今天我们要聊一个我觉得讨论远远不够的话题，尤其是在我们二十岁这个年龄段，或者其实在任何年龄段都是如此，尽管它比我们想象的要普遍得多，
or are at risk of developing a serious illness, that our death or some kind of serious harm is either inevitable or currently occurring somewhere in our bodies. Even if we don't have symptoms, we misinterpret normal bodily sensations as dangerous. and it's that very fear that we may secretly have a condition like cancer or that we're having a heart attack or something else that can actually produce feelings that are similar to those conditions that we expect that we have because it activates our anxiety and a fear response such that we no longer really feel in touch with our bodies. This cycle can mean that we need constant reassurance from doctors. We're always scheduling appointments, search
那就是健康焦虑，也就是害怕或过度沉迷于这样一种信念：我们目前正在患病，或者面临罹难严重疾病的风险，我们的死亡或某种严重的伤害要么是不可避免的，要么正在我们体内的某个地方发生。即使我们没有任何症状，我们也会将正常的身体感觉误解为危险的。正是这种对我们可能秘密患有癌症等疾病、或是正在心脏病发作或其他什么的恐惧，实际上会产生类似于我们预期的那些病症的感觉，因为它会激活我们的焦虑和恐惧反应，以至于我们觉得仿佛与自己的身体失去了真实的联系。这种循环意味着我们需要医生不断的安慰。我们总是预约看病，在网上搜索
for answers on the internet and we are constantly coming up with this new explanation for a sensation or feeling that is either not that serious or may not even exist. The thing is though is that it's our anxiety that triggers our imagination to go to the worst possible outcome. And that is where we land and that is where we stay. On a personal note, health anxiety is something I've dealt with on and off for the greater part of my 20s, I would say even my teen years as well before that. And I want to really speak about that experience today for others who might be able to relate, but also just kind of sharing what I've learned and how I have come to manage the at times real chronic anxiety that something in my body is not quite right.
答案，并且我们不断为某种感觉或情绪想出新的解释，而这种感觉或情绪要么没那么严重，要么甚至根本不存在。但关键在于，是我们的焦虑触发了我们的想象，让我们走向最糟糕的可能结果。而这就是我们最终落脚并停留的地方。就我个人而言，健康焦虑是我在二十岁的大部分时间里断断续续一直在应对的问题，我甚至可以说在我之前的十几岁时就已经开始了。今天我真的想谈谈这段经历，希望能引起其他人的共鸣，同时也分享一下我所学到的知识，以及我是如何学会管理有时真实而慢性的焦虑——即我身体里的某个地方不太对劲。
But also where this unique type of anxiety or set of fears comes from, whether it is hypervigilant parents, catastrophic thinking, our intolerance for uncertainty, fear mongering, there is so much to be said for the origins of this kind of unique type of anxiety. There is actually a term for the fact that a lot of us believe that we have certain conditions because of our exposure to the internet. It's called cyberchondria where we repeatedly Google our symptoms and look for examples that kind of justify our own explanations to ourselves. Honestly, I think talking about this in the aftermath of a global pandemic is also so important because I think COVID and the changes that that brought to the world around us have been such a huge catalyst for so many people when it comes to health fears and health worries.
还有这种独特的焦虑或一系列恐惧究竟源自何处，无论是过度警惕的父母、灾难化的思维、我们对不确定性的不容忍、贩卖焦虑，关于这种独特焦虑的根源，有太多话可说了。事实上，对于我们许多人因为接触互联网而相信自己患有某种疾病这一现象，还有一个专门的术语。这被称为网络疑病症（cyberchondria），即我们反复谷歌搜索自己的症状，寻找那种为自己对自己的解释提供合理依据的例子。说实话，我觉得在全球大流行之后谈论这个也极为重要，因为我认为新冠疫情及其给周围世界带来的变化，对于许多人在健康恐惧和健康担忧方面来说，是一个巨大的催化剂。
I think when we are in our 20s, we're expected to feel very invincible because we are young. This is normally when we are our healthiest, our fittest, our immune system is strong. we think we're going to live forever. But we also have this very instinctual urge to want to stay alive for as long as possible. And that means worrying about our health, especially if you're an especially anxious person. Our minds like to find anything in our environment, external or internal, to be hypervigilant towards so that we are aware of any threats. I remember vividly when the Ebola virus was making like international health.
我想当我们二十岁的时候，我们本应觉得自己是战无不胜的，因为我们年轻。这通常是我们最健康、体能最好、免疫系统最强的时候，我们觉得自己能长生不老。但我们同时也有着一种非常本能的冲动，想要尽可能久地活下去。这意味着我们要担忧自己的健康，特别是如果你是一个格外焦虑的人。我们的内心喜欢在环境中寻找任何东西——无论是外部的还是内部的——并对之保持高度警惕，以便我们能意识到任何威胁。我清晰地记得当埃博拉病毒成为国际健康头条新闻的时候
headlines back in 2014, 2015, and I was so scared. I was terrified that my entire family was going to be infected with this rare disease and die. I would Google survival rates and symptoms. I'm pretty sure I ordered one of those like protective suits on Amazon using my mom's credit card. Anytime I had a cough, the smallest pain, even the hiccups, I would go into a state of panic. And I didn't really have a term for what that feeling was, the constant Googling, the anxiety, the endless doctor's appointments for symptoms that would disappear as soon as they told me I was fine. But it was when I was in my 20s that someone finally said to me like, hey, look, it's unlikely that you are suffering from every rare disease on the planet and that you're still alive. I think the underlying condition here is really
早在2014、2015年，我当时吓坏了。我恐慌地认为我的整个家族都会被这种罕见的疾病感染并死去。我会谷歌搜索存活率和症状。我很确定我用我妈的信用卡在亚马逊上订购了那种防护服之一。每当我咳嗽、有一点最小的疼痛，甚至打嗝，我都会陷入恐慌状态。我当时其实并不知道那种感觉到底叫什么名字，不断地谷歌搜索、焦虑、为了那些一听说我没事就会消失的症状而无休止地去看医生。但正是在我二十岁的时候，终于有人对我说：“嘿，听着，你不太可能患有地球上所有的罕见病，而且你现在居然还活着。”我想这里的潜在状况其实是
health anxiety. This was after I'd been experiencing headaches for a few weeks and I had my friend Kate, God bless her, an actual angel, but she drove me to get an emergency MRI because I was convinced to the point of thinking I would need to write my will that I had a serious brain clot or terminal cancer. Spoiler alert, it was neither. I had just become so hypervigilant towards any abnormalities and how I was feeling so alert to my body, so consumed with my worry and my stress, that I was experiencing these phantom symptoms, or I was applying unreasonable, irrational explanations to things that are just normal to experience as a human being that is going through life.
健康焦虑。这是在我连续几周头痛之后发生的，当时我的朋友凯特（Kate），上帝保佑她，真的是个天使，她开车送我去做了紧急核磁共振，因为我确信自己脑子里有严重的血栓或晚期癌症，甚至觉得自己必须开始写遗嘱了。剧透一下，两者都不是。我只是对身体感受到的任何异常变得过于警惕，对自己的身体如此敏感，以至于被担忧和压力压垮，从而产生了这些幻觉症状，或者将那些经历生活的人来说再正常不过的事情，加上了不合理、不理性的解释。
That explanation actually brought me a lot of peace. Even if at times I still feel a lot of my anxiety spike, I understand it now. I can apply logic and understanding to my needs. to go searching for answers. And you know what it really all comes down to? It feels terrible to not be in control of your body. It is scary to feel like you are out of touch with what's going on inside of you and to realize and recognize your vulnerability as a human. That is the origin of the fear. Understanding that although illness and sickness is a part of life, we want to be prepared for whatever is possible. We want to be able to avoid anything that might happen. So we experience a lot of
这种解释实际上给了我内心极大的平静。尽管有时我仍然会感到焦虑急剧飙升，但我现在理解它了。我可以运用逻辑和理解来满足我寻找答案的需求。你知道这归根结底是什么吗？无法掌控自己的身体感觉太糟糕了。感觉自己对体内发生的事情失去掌控，并意识到自己作为人类的脆弱性，这种感觉是很可怕的。这就是恐惧的根源。我们要明白，尽管疾病是生活的一部分，但我们希望为任何可能的情况做好准备。我们希望能够避免任何可能发生的事情。所以我们经历了很多
false alarms. I would always rationalize it that it was better safe than sorry, but I think I actually wasn't being safe. I was just creating more stress for myself. So what are some of the roots, the root causes of our health anxiety? Because I think being aware of those first allows us to actually gain the control that we feel or sense that we lack. To understand health anxiety, we firstly have to really consider our evolutionary history and the fact that we all are at the end of the day just animals just another species whose primary goal is survival. Anxiety is a protective mechanism that serves that purpose and it allows us to scan the body for an illness that we might need to protect ourselves from. Our ancestors really relied on that
虚惊一场。我总是自我合理化，觉得小心驶得万年船总没错，但我认为我其实并没有在保证安全。我只是在给自己制造更多的压力。那么，我们健康焦虑的根源，也就是根本原因是什么呢？因为我认为首先意识到这些，能让我们真正获得我们感觉或认为自己缺乏的掌控感。要理解健康焦虑，我们首先必须真正审视我们的进化史，以及归根结底我们都只是动物这一事实——我们只是另一个物种，其首要目标就是生存。焦虑是一种服务于该目的的保护机制，它使我们能够扫描身体，寻找我们可能需要保护自己免受其害的疾病。我们的祖先确实依赖那种
keen sense of hypervigilance to survive in a hostile environment, one that they couldn't always predict. So those of us who are more cautious about potential threats were more likely to survive, more likely to pass on our genes. Normally we would interpret that as being threats in our environment, like a massive tiger coming to eat us or predators. And in many ways that is true. That is what ancient hypervigilance was normally directed towards outside threats. But as we've evolved, As a species, this hypervigilance has now turned inward. We are now on high alert for signs of illness because that illness is just as dangerous as something external or in our environment. And we now have the knowledge to treat and eliminate the threat.
敏锐的高度警惕性，才得以在一个充满敌意、且无法总是预测的环境中生存下来。因此，我们当中那些对潜在威胁更加谨慎的人更有可能生存下来，更有可能将基因传递下去。通常我们会将其解释为环境中的威胁，比如一头大老虎来吃我们或其他捕食者。在许多方面，这确实是真的。古代的高度警惕性通常就是针对外部威胁的。但随着我们作为物种的进化，这种高度警惕性现在已经转向了内部。我们现在对疾病的征兆处于高度戒备状态，因为这种疾病和外部或环境中的东西一样危险。而且我们现在拥有了治疗和消除这种威胁的知识。
Therefore, if we catch something early enough, maybe we'll be okay. So we start looking for signs that what we are experiencing is a larger problem to get that diagnostic care. Another part of our programming or I guess our basic instincts as humans that has made us more aware of potential sickness or conditions is the innate and automatic prioritization of negative information. This is known as a negativity bias. So basically we are more likely to attend to, learn from, focus on negative information more than positive information. and that bias, that tendency has been with us since infancy. It's something that is so important to our survival that even as children, we do it. Because you have to know that if you have a beautiful rainbow on one side and a terrible storm on the other,
因此，如果我们能足够早地发现问题，也许我们就不会有事。所以我们开始寻找迹象，证明我们正在经历的是一个更大的问题，从而去获得诊断护理。我们编程的另一部分，或者说作为人类的基本本能，让我们更加意识到潜在的疾病或状况，那就是对负面信息的先天和自动优先处理。这被称为负面偏误（negativity bias）。因此，基本上我们比正面信息更有可能关注、了解并聚焦于负面信息。这种偏误、这种倾向从婴儿时期就伴随着我们。这对我们的生存至关重要，甚至作为孩子，我们也会这样做。因为你必须知道，如果你的一侧有一道美丽的彩虹，另一侧有一场可怕的风暴，
prioritizing the storm, thinking about how you're going to escape or protect yourself, was more likely to mean that you would survive. So we focus on that negative information. When we think about that in the context of health anxiety, this means that we are hardwired to excessively focus on the worst possible outcome. We magnify and amplify the perceived threat or small minor symptoms into a catastrophic illness. That small pain on your side, that's a heart attack. That headache, it's a brain tumor. And that catastrophic thinking has obviously emerged to help us, but in a modern context, it actually does,
优先关注风暴，思考你将如何逃生或保护自己，意味着你更有可能生存下来。所以我们专注于那些负面信息。当我们把这一点放在健康焦虑的背景下来看时，这意味着我们生来就倾向于过度关注最有可能的最坏结果。我们将感知到的威胁或微小的轻微症状放大并夸大了，将其变成了一种灾难性的疾病。你侧腹的那一丝疼痛，那是心脏病发作。那个头痛，那是脑瘤。这种灾难性的思维显然是为了帮助我们而出现的，但在现代背景下，它实际上却会
more harm than good because we can't help but think of an explanation first before there is actually a reason to think that. So it reinforces our cycle of anxiety. The next thing we need to appreciate is that when we are struggling with our health anxiety, what we really are struggling with at the end of the day is our intolerance of uncertainty. A lot of this, if you haven't realized, is once again, coming down to our innate human nature and our fear of the unknown. We don't like it as humans when we don't know what's going to happen next, when we don't feel a sense of control, when we are just uncertain.
产生弊大于利的影响，因为我们情不自禁地会在有理由去思考之前，先想出一个解释。所以它强化了我们的焦虑循环。我们接下来需要认识到的是，当我们与健康焦虑作斗争时，归根结底我们真正与之作斗争的是我们对不确定性的不容忍。如果你还没有意识到的话，这其中很大一部分再次归结于我们天生的人性以及我们对未知的恐惧。作为人类，当我们不知道接下来会发生什么、当我们感觉不到控制感、当我们只是处于不确定状态时，我们会感到很不舒服。
That leaves room for danger. Uncertainty is obviously a really normal part of life. We can never be 100% sure about what the future holds, not even 50%, 20%, good and bad. However, if you already have a high baseline or high level, of anxiety, you are more likely to want to plan and prepare for everything as a way of eliminating ambiguity or uncertainty because we are so fearful of it. It's why we like going to the same restaurants, where we like watching the same comfort TV shows or movies or only going to
这留下了危险的空间。不确定性显然是生活当中非常正常的一部分。我们永远无法百分之百确定未来会怎样，甚至连50%、20%都做不到，有好的也有坏的。然而，如果你本身就有着很高的基线或很高水平的焦虑，你更有可能想要为一切事情做出计划和准备，以此来消除含糊不清或不确定性，因为我们对它太害怕了。这就是为什么我们喜欢去同一家餐馆，为什么我们喜欢看同一部让人感到舒适的电视剧或电影，或者只去
parties or social events where we know people. It minimizes the things that will be out of our control. However, our health is not something we can always control and realizing that that creates further worry. We can become infected with something from a thoughtless cough or from pure chance, some genetic mutation that has just happened. So we overthink every small thing in order to mitigate our sense of stress at that realization. It's where a lot of those symptoms are coming from, the fear of uncertainty. There's a lot of reasons why we do that, but it normally comes down to two main sources. Firstly, is our upbringing and past experiences, and second is the internet. We are going to discuss how these two things contribute
那些我们认识人的派对或社交活动。它将那些超出我们控制的事情降到最低。然而，我们的健康并不是我们总是能控制的东西，意识到这一点会产生进一步的担忧。我们可能会因为一次不经意的咳嗽或纯粹的运气——某种刚好发生的基因突变——而被传染某种疾病。因此，我们过度思考每一件小事，以减轻我们在意识到这一点时的压力感。许多此类症状正是由此而生——对不确定性的恐惧。我们这样做的原因有很多，但通常可以归结为两个主要来源。首先是我们的成长经历和过往经历，其次是互联网。我们将探讨这两件事是如何导致
to our health anxiety, but also how we can begin to manage these feelings in a very healthy, sustainable, helpful way after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
我们的健康焦虑的，以及在短暂的休息之后，我们如何开始以一种非常健康、可持续、有帮助的方式来管理这些情绪。2%. 这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中精神韧性、健身以及建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些困难，你会以一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。请在I-Hart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·因（Alex In）。在每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我随时都可以谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，到了这个时候，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark, Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难抉择》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark），有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上做个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
我希望你们能真正做一个好人。加入我凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway）并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle, to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
发现自己处于父子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战，以证明真相。你把这个特定的检测测试篡改了两次，以至于。我篡改了一次检测。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才破案。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马林奇尼（Michael Marincini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱之陷阱》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When I was a child, I used to get these really, really terrible stomach pains. Like the worst pain that you have ever experienced, it felt like someone was ripping out my organs. And I would complain about this to my parents all the time.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。请在Iheart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱之陷阱》播客。当我还是个孩子的时候，我经常胃痛得非常非常厉害。就像你经历过的最糟糕的痛，感觉就像有人在撕裂我的内脏。我经常向父母抱怨这件事。
It would come on randomly when I was at school, when I was with my friends, when I was playing basketball. And my parents would always dismiss it. They'd be like, no, you were just overreacting. It took over a year for them to realize that something was actually wrong. And when we went to the doctor, they found out that I had this really random. random condition, especially for people like under the age of 40. I'm not going to go into what it is, but basically this condition is super, super rare unless you're like over 40 and you're suffering from obesity and like high blood pressure and a poor
它会在我上学时、和朋友在一起时、打篮球时随机发作。而我的父母总是对此不以为然。他们会说，不，你只是反应过度了。他们花了一年多的时间才意识到真的出问题了。当我们去看医生时，他们发现我患有一种非常罕见的、随机的疾病。随机的病情，特别是对于40岁以下的人来说。我不打算具体说明它是什么，但基本上这种病情超级超级罕见，除非你年过40，并且正遭受肥胖、高血压以及糟糕的
diet. And it's also really, really painful. And you know, my parents never could have known that this is what was going on because who is going to think that their 12 year old daughter has a condition that mostly impacts sedentary, pregnant, adult women with high cholesterol. That memory, though, of knowing for a while that something was wrong, trying to communicate that, not being believed, that really stuck with me. We think that those memories, those childhood experiences aren't important,
饮食的困扰。而且这也非常非常痛苦。你知道，我父母怎么也想不到这会是这么一回事，因为谁会认为他们12岁的女儿会得一种主要影响久坐不动、怀孕、有高胆固醇的成年女性的疾病呢？然而，那段记忆——那种一度知道有些不对劲、试图沟通却不被相信的记忆——真的深深地刻在了我的脑海里。我们认为那些记忆、那些童年的经历并不重要，
and we think that we don't subliminally learn from them. But those are teachable moments, and our brain takes those times when we were in pain, or experiencing hurt or something damaging and holds onto those memories really tightly because they might be useful in the future. So I look at that experience as being a big origin point for me because whilst my rational brain can see that this was really rare, this was really out of the blue, it wasn't life-threatening,
而且我们认为我们不会潜意识地从中汲取教训。但那些都是可以汲取教训的时刻，我们的大脑会抓住那些我们处于痛苦中、经历伤害或破坏性事件的时刻，并紧紧抓住这些记忆，因为它们在未来可能会有用。所以我把这段经历看作是我个人的一个巨大发端点，因为虽然我的理性大脑能看出这真的很罕见、这真的很突发、它并不危及生命、
it was managed, all that that situation taught me was just how little control that we have, how little we know about what our bodies are doing. And I'm not trying to use that example to like fearmonger. I'm just more so using it to illustrate my point that childhood experiences and moments from our upbringing play a really pivotal role in the development of health anxiety. Individuals who may be experienced frequent illness when they were children or had a significant loss in childhood grow up associating health-related issues with deep emotional pain. these unresolved emotions can resurface in the form of this health anxiety, where the fear of illness becomes intertwined with this unresolved trauma. Further to that, some of us have also been raised with parents or family members who themselves are hypercontriacs,
它得到了控制，但那次情况所教给我的全部内容，仅仅是我们对事物缺乏多少控制，我们对身体正在做的事情了解得多么少。我并不是想用这个例子来贩卖焦虑。我更多地是用它来阐明我的观点：童年经历和成长过程中的时刻在健康焦虑的发展中起到了极其关键的作用。那些在童年中可能经历过频繁生病或在童年遭受重大丧失的个人，长大后会将与健康相关的问题与深层的精神痛苦联系起来。这些未解决的情绪可能会以健康焦虑的形式浮出水面，在这里，对疾病的恐惧与这种未解决的创伤交织在了一起。除此之外，我们中的有些人是由父母或家庭成员抚养长大的，他们自己就是极度疑病症患者，
and they project their fears onto us as a way of coping with their own personal anxiety. It might have been a mother who was always sanitizing things, taking you to the doctor, keeping you home from school. these experiences imprint on us, they stay with us, we begin to mimic it through observational learning, and then when we become adults who have been raised in this way, where those behaviors we thought kept us safe and provided a sense of, you know, false sense of security, we begin to take those on ourselves. It may also be that someone in your family has unfortunately suffered from a really terrible disease or condition. And so you know firsthand what that looks like and you want to avoid it at all costs. A family member with a condition also creates a predisposition, which may give you
他们将自己的恐惧投射到我们身上，以此来应对他们自己的个人焦虑。那可能是一个总是给东西消毒、带你去看医生、把你留在家里不上学的母亲。这些经历在我们的身上留下了印记，它们伴随着我们，我们开始通过观察学习来模仿它，然后当我们成为以这种方式长大的成年人时——我们认为这些行为能让我们保持安全并提供一种（你知道的）虚假的安全感——我们开始将这些行为内化到自己身上。也可能是你家里的某个人不幸遭受了某种非常可怕的疾病或病症的折磨。所以你亲眼目睹了那是什么样子的，你希望不惜一切代价避免它。有病情缠身的家庭成员也会产生一种易感倾向，这可能会给你
more reason and justification for your excessive worry because now you feel more at risk. You feel more in danger. It also creates what we call a frequency illusion or a frequency bias where we tend to to notice something more after we notice it for the first time, leading to the belief that it is more common than it is. An example is that if your family member has Parkinson's, the more you're going to start seeing Parkinson's in the news, in the media, overhearing it on the street in conversations, leading to the belief that you should actually be more afraid, when really it's just an illusion created by where your brain is deciding to direct attention. This is really only aided by the fact that most of us belong to the first ever generation that grew up on the internet.
的过度担忧提供更多理由和正当性，因为现在你觉得自己面临的风险更大。你觉得更危险了。它还产生了我们所说的频率错觉（frequency illusion）或频率偏误（frequency bias），即我们在第一次注意到某事后，往往会注意到更多，从而导致我们相信它比实际情况更常见。一个例子是，如果你的家庭成员患有帕金森病，你就会越发地在新闻、媒体中看到帕金森病，在街上的对话中无意听到它，从而让你相信你应该更加害怕，而实际上这只是你大脑决定将注意力导向何处所产生的错觉。这一现象仅仅得到了以下事实的助力：我们大多数人都属于第一代在互联网上长大的人。
And we know that the internet loves fearmongering, it loves clickbait, novel stories that capture our attention, that get more likes, that get more views. Because people are naturally drawn to information that is more emotionally charged. So those stories of cancer patients and rare diseases and infections, they become more salient, especially once again in the minds of anxious people who are already on high alert for this information. The internet is very quick to give you the worst possible answer to any question that you ask it. I think this is a common experience to be like Googling your minor stomach pains at 2am and the first response is that you have some uncurable infection and you'll be like dead in three weeks. That is what we were talking about before, hypochondria. even if we are Googling our symptoms in the first place as a way to seek reassurance,
我们知道互联网喜欢贩卖焦虑，它喜欢点击诱饵、能够吸引我们眼球、获得更多点赞、获得更多浏览量的新奇故事。因为人们天生就被那些更具情感色彩的信息所吸引。所以那些癌症患者、罕见病和感染的故事变得更加突出，尤其是再次在那些已经对这些信息高度戒备的焦虑人群的心中。互联网非常迅速地为你提出的任何问题提供最糟糕的可能答案。我认为这是一种常见的经历：在凌晨2点用谷歌搜索你轻微的胃痛，得到的第一个回应是你感染了某种无法治愈的感染，三周内就会死掉。这就是我们之前谈到的网络疑病症。即使我们起初谷歌搜索自己的症状是为了寻求安慰，
suddenly you're given this like unexpected answer and you're thinking, oh yeah, I fit the profile for all of these things because you have this bias, right? You want to meet this profile. You've been told the answer so you want to make sure that you are part of the answer because Dr. Google has told you so and you trust that information. So how do we counteract that? if we know we have this tendency, if it is creating concern for us, meaning that we are in that constant state of panic, what are our strategies here? Because I think the most important thing to
突然间你得到了这个意料之外的答案，你心想：“哦，是的，我符合所有这些情况的特征，”因为你有这种偏误，对吧？你希望符合这个特征。既然有人告诉你了答案，你就会想确保自己是这个答案的一部分，因为“谷歌医生”已经告诉你了，而你信任这些信息。那么我们如何对抗这一点呢？如果我们知道自己有这种倾向，如果它正在给我们带来担忧，意味着我们处于那种持续的恐慌状态中，我们的策略是什么？因为我认为最重要的事情
remember is that when you have anxiety of any sort, your thoughts are still within your control. They originate from you. Your anxieties, your worries, they come from you. They can be controlled by you, even if it seems hard. So there's three main strategies here that I want to talk about. Firstly, get comfortable with uncomfortable feelings. A lot of our health anxiety comes from feeling disconnected with our bodies and experiencing phantom symptoms, which we know are actually the result of our anxiety. These feelings make us very aware of our bodies and also very aware of of the stress response that we're going through. And so if we're not comfortable with that discomfort
要记住的是，当你患有任何形式的焦虑时，你的思想仍然在你的控制之内。它们源自于你。你的焦虑，你的担忧，都来自于你。它们可以由你控制，尽管这看起来很难。所以这里有三个我想要讨论的主要策略。首先，学会适应不舒服的感觉。我们的健康焦虑很大程度上来自于与身体失去连接并经历幻觉症状，我们知道这些症状实际上是我们焦虑的结果。这些感觉让我们对自己的身体有了高度的感知，同时也对我们正在经历的压力反应有了高度的感知。所以如果我们不习惯那种不适感
and cannot identify the true origin, which is a false alarm or a fear response, we're going to read further into that. And the next thing you know, we're in the doctor's office. If you think about it, a lot of the symptoms of anxiety also mimic a lot of the symptoms of more serious illnesses. So we can't tell the difference and we're not,
并且无法识别真实的根源——即虚假的警报或恐惧反应——我们会对此过度解读。接下来你知道的，我们就在医生的办公室里了。如果你仔细想想，焦虑的许多症状也模仿了许多更严重疾病的症状。所以我们分不清区别，而且我们不，
we don't feel safe in those feelings. A lot of these sensations, we can actually bring back into our control using methods associated with this idea called biofeedback. So biofeedback is this idea in psychology that we can actually train our minds to influence what we typically see is automatic bodily functions as a way to restore a sense of mental stability. There's the things like using like breathing patterns to control heart rate or meditation to control racing thoughts. the easiest way to tell whether your racing heartbeat is a heart attack or just anxiety is to stop for a
我们在这些感觉中觉得不安全。其中许多感觉，我们可以通过与称为生物反馈（biofeedback）的概念相关的方法重新将其纳入我们的控制之中。因此，生物反馈是心理学中的一个概念，即我们实际上可以训练我们的思维来影响我们通常视为自动的身体功能，以此来恢复心理稳定感。比如使用呼吸模式来控制心率，或者通过冥想来控制狂飙的思绪。判断你的狂飙心跳是心脏病发作还是仅仅是焦虑的最简单方法是停下
second take eight really deep breaths let your arms float lie down flat continue to breathe and i want you to think of your anxiety as a bubble slowly flowing past you or like a shell in the waves that are slowly getting swept out picture the most beautiful place you've ever been, focus on that anxiety floating away, moving out of your line of sight, and start focusing on the environment that you're imagining around you. Identify five things you can see in that place. What are you smelling? What are you hearing? What are you feeling? And has your heart rate dropped? Is your breathing more in your control? That is a sign that this is a symptom of anxiety, not a real illness. I also do this thing where when I'm like getting those
一秒，做八次真正的深呼吸，让你的手臂放松，平躺下来，继续呼吸，我希望你把你的焦虑想象成一个缓缓流过你的气泡，或者像海浪中慢慢被卷走的贝壳。想象你去过的最美丽的那个地方，专注于那种焦虑漂浮开去、移出你的视线，并开始专注于你想象中周围的环境。找出你在这个地方能看到的五件事。你在闻到什么？你在听到什么？你在感受到什么？你的心率降下来了吗？你的呼吸更加在你的控制之下了吗？这是一个迹象，表明这是焦虑的症状，而不是真正的疾病。我还会做这样一件事：当我产生那些我们都非常、非常熟悉的
racing thoughts that we all are so, so familiar with, I visualize all of my anxiety resting in the palm of my hand and I concentrate all of my worries onto that area. They're just in my hand. They're not anywhere else in my body. I hold onto them tightly and then slowly I let them go, but only when I'm ready to. And until that point, they stay right there in the palm of my hand. They're not in my mind. They're not anywhere else in my body. I can see them. I know where they're going to go. And they're not going to hurt me. And I slowly release them. That is a really important tactic for me because it stops me from feeling like my anxiety is this thing that has control over me and I actually have control of it yet. I also would say begin to notice when you experience these phantom symptoms
狂飙思绪时，我将我所有的焦虑可视化，让它们停留在我的手掌心，并将我所有的担忧集中在这个区域。它们只在我的手心里。它们不在我身体的其他任何地方。我紧紧抓住它们，然后慢慢地放手，但只有当我准备好时才这么做。直到那一刻，它们都静静地呆在我的手心。它们不在我的脑海里。它们不在我身体的其他任何地方。我能看到它们。我知道它们要去哪里。它们不会伤害我。然后我慢慢地释放它们。对我来说这是一个非常重要的策略，因为它阻止了我那种认为焦虑是掌控着我的东西的感觉，而实际上是我在掌控着它。我还会说，开始注意你何时会经历这些幻觉症状
as a way to rationalize them and better understand your triggers. Is it that you often start to feel like you have a sickness or an illness or a condition during periods of really high stress after you've had a really tough conversation with your partner when you've had a really busy day? Often there is an environmental catalyst and our health anxiety is really just us projecting a sense of uncertainty in our lives onto uncertainty around our health, that feels more serious and valid to worry about. That's okay.
以此来合理化它们并更好地理解你的诱因。是不是当你在经历极高压力的时期时——比如在与伴侣进行了一次艰难的对话之后、在你度过了非常忙碌的一天之后——你经常开始觉得你得了一种疾病、病症或状况？通常会有一个环境催化剂，而我们的健康焦虑实际上只是我们将生活中的不确定感投射到了对健康的担忧上，这让人觉得更严重、更值得担忧。这没关系。
Sometimes our mind does what it needs to do to compartmentalize our stress, but it is about being aware of that. Secondly, invest in your health as a way to build your confidence instead of Googling or instead of searching for answers. At the end of the day, our health is really precious, health is wealth, it's so important, that is why we are so protective of it. and so hypervigilant towards things that might be going wrong. But we have to remember that our health anxiety is really just us unconsciously trying to do what's
有时我们的大脑会做它需要做的事情来将压力进行区隔，但关键是要意识到这一点。其次，投资于你的健康来建立你的自信，而不是去谷歌搜索或寻找答案。归根结底，我们的健康真的很宝贵，健康就是财富，它太重要了，这就是为什么我们如此保护它，
right by ourselves by being overly cautious. Our brain just doesn't realize when it's maybe gone too far. Flip the narrative. Instead of looking for illness, look for ways to promote wellness. Let me explain this a little bit more. If you feel healthy, if you feel well, if you know that you are fit, taking care of yourself, that entire bodily sensation is going to give you peace of mind and a much deeper sense of confidence that you are in fact totally fine, you're okay. So instead of overthinking
并对可能出错的事情保持高度警惕。但我们必须记住，我们的健康焦虑实际上只是我们在无意识地试图通过过度谨慎来做对自己正确的事。我们的大脑只是没有意识到它可能已经走得太远了。扭转叙事。不要去寻找疾病，而是去寻找促进健康的方法。让我再多解释一点。如果你觉得自己很健康，如果你感觉很好，如果你知道自己身体很好、在照顾自己，那么整个身体的感受会给你带来内心的平静，以及更深层次的自信——即你实际上完全没事，你很好。所以与其过度思考
and Googling, go for a walk instead, prioritize exercise, eat foods that make you feel good, go and get your regular checkups, take your vitamins, get eight hours of sleep, make that your focus instead of your worries. It's going to have two effects. Number one, you're just going to feel a lot better and your anxiety will actually just be lessened because you're adopting these healthy habits. And secondly, it brings that sense of control back into your life. You feel like the control that you're giving up when you worry about your health, you are reclaiming by prioritizing your health. If that doesn't work, you can always challenge these unhelpful thoughts. Anxiety is irrational, helpful thoughts are logical. What are the actual prevalence rates of what you're worried about
和谷歌搜索，不如去散步，优先考虑锻炼，吃让你感觉良好的食物，定期去体检，吃维生素，保证八个小时的睡眠，把这些作为你的焦点，而不是你的担忧。这会产生两个效果。第一，你会感觉好很多，而且由于你养成了这些健康的习惯，你的焦虑实际上会减轻。第二，它将这种控制感带回了你的生活。你觉得你在为健康担忧时放弃的控制权，正在通过优先考虑健康来重新夺回。如果这不管用，你总是可以挑战这些没有帮助的想法。焦虑是不理性的，有帮助的想法是理性的。你所担心的实际患病率到底是多少
here? How common is it really? What are your chances of surviving? How would doctors treat you if this was to happen? Is there a more rational explanation for your symptoms? You've got to realize that if something was really wrong, your body is going to tell you in ways that are very obvious. You would not have any doubts and worst case scenario, you would still be okay. I promise you, you are going to be okay. Our medical system is so far advanced. Often we forget that. We feel like we have to do all the work to keep ourselves safe when there are people who have trained for years to do that for us. Sometimes we think that our, you know, anxious thoughts are the only things protecting us. Like, if I can outthink my anxiety or if I overthink something enough, I'll jinx it and it can't
这里？这到底有多普遍？你康复的机会有多大？如果发生这种情况，医生会怎么治疗你？对你的症状有没有更理性的解释？你必须明白，如果真的出了什么问题，你的身体会以非常明显的方式告诉你。你不会有任何怀疑，最坏的情况下，你仍然会没事。我向你保证，你会没事的。我们的医疗系统非常先进。我们常常忘记这一点。当我们觉得自己必须付出全部努力来保证自身安全时，却忘记了有人已经为此接受了多年的专业训练。有时我们会认为，你知道，焦虑的想法是唯一能保护我们的东西。比如，如果我能克服焦虑，或者如果我想得足够多，我就能摆脱厄运，它就不会
possibly come true. But your anxiety is lying to you. Your nervous system has developed a fight or flight response and sometimes it means it misfires. Our health anxiety is an instant of that. So my final tip when you can't escape this spiral or your thoughts are just really loud today is to talk it out with your friends. And I find this really helpful for two reasons. Firstly, when you verbalise something, you often realize how silly it sounds. And secondly, you'll be surprised
可能成真。但你的焦虑在对你撒谎。你的神经系统已经发展出了战斗或逃跑反应，有时这意味着它会失火。我们的健康焦虑就是其中的一个例子。所以我的最后一个建议是，当你无法摆脱这种恶性循环，或者今天你的想法真的很强烈时，去和你的朋友倾诉。我发现这非常有用，原因有二。首先，当你把事情说出口时，你往往会意识到它听起来有多么荒谬。其次，你会惊讶于
how many other people out there have similar thoughts to you at some time or another. I remember so clearly sitting down with my friend Kate when she was about to take me to get that MRI and just hearing from her how she felt the same way. Obviously, I knew how hard it was, so it wasn't like a pleasure to hear. I wasn't like happy.
有多少其他人曾在某个时候和你有过相似的想法。我清晰地记得，当我的朋友凯特准备带我去拍核磁共振时，我和她坐在一起，听她讲述她也有同样的感受。显然我知道这有多难，所以这并不是一件让人高兴的事，我并不是觉得开心。
But I believe that seeing our experiences reflected back on us is one of the most calming, reassuring things we can feel. It makes you realize that no feeling that we experience is felt alone. No human experience is completely unique or experienced in solitude. We operate in the same way as humans, our quirks, our anxieties, our insecurities. That is a good feeling. That is a comforting feeling. talk about it openly, discuss it with your friends and your family, and they can kind of act as a voice of reason in those situations when your logic is failing you.
但我相信，看到我们的经历在别人身上得到映照，是我们能感受到的最平静、最安心的事情之一。它让你意识到，我们经历的任何感受都不是孤单的。没有任何人类的体验是完全独特或在孤独中经历的。我们作为人类的运作方式是一样的，我们的怪癖、我们的焦虑、我们的不安全感。这是一种美好的感觉。这是一种安慰的感觉。公开谈论它，和你的朋友、家人讨论它，在你的逻辑失效时，他们可以在某种程度上充当理智的声音。
They are kind of the rational voice that you need because once again in those moments, your brain is just looking for a source of fear. It is fearmongering. It wants answers. It wants certainty. So it's going to find whatever explanation is going to bring it comfort and peace, even if it's not the right. one, even if it's totally off the mark. I really do have a lot of sympathy. I feel like if you can't tell it, this is part of my reality.
它们在某种程度上是你需要的理智声音，因为在那些时刻，你的大脑只是在寻找恐惧的源头。它在贩卖焦虑。它想要答案。它想要确定性。所以它会找到任何能带来安慰和平静的解释，即使它不是正确的，即使它完全偏离了目标。我真的有很多同情心。我觉得如果你看不出来，这也是我现实的一部分。
And sometimes it's really, really hard. I've been, like, traveling a lot recently. And I think that's a big trigger for me where I get really worried that I'll get sick when I'm overseas. So I start becoming really hypervigilant to, like, any small thing as like a reason not to go or as like a reason to go to the doctor. So it's definitely been on my mind. And I want you to know that.
有时这真的非常非常难。我最近经常旅行。我认为这是一个很大的诱因，让我非常担心在海外生病。所以我开始对任何小事都保持高度警惕，把它作为不去的理由，或者去看医生的理由。所以这绝对一直在我的脑海里。我想让你知道的是，
you are not alone. Obviously, as I was saying that about talking to friends and being reassured by other people's experiences, I hope you can hear my experience and realize that you are not the only one who was conscious of this, who was conscious of these worries and these anxieties. You are going to be completely fine. You are going to be so okay. I'm really rooting for you. I know it can be hard to feel like you are not in control of your body because of whatever experience in the past, scared for your future, the future of your health and your well-being, but I'm right there with you and I really get it. So I hope this episode has been of some help. I hope these strategies have been helpful. They personally are amazing for me. I really do hope you enjoyed this episode or at least
你并不孤单。显然，正如我刚才所说，和朋友交谈并从别人的经历中得到安慰，我希望你能听到我的经历，并意识到你并不是唯一一个意识到这一点的人，唯一一个意识到这些担忧和焦虑的人。你完全会没事的。你会非常好的。我真的很支持你。我知道，由于过去的某种经历，你会觉得无法掌控自己的身体，为你的未来、你的健康和福祉的未来感到害怕，这是很难受的，但我一直和你在一起，我真的很理解。所以希望这一集能提供一些帮助。希望这些策略对你有所帮助。它们对我个人来说真的很棒。我真的希望你喜欢这一集，或者至少
got something out of it. As always, if there is someone who needs to hear this, please feel free to share it along, to share the love, and make sure that you leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast, Spotify, wherever you're listening. I read them all. I see them all. I see them all. they made me feel so happy and I can't believe that we have this beautiful community of people who care about these things. So thank you so much for coming along for the ride. If you have an episode suggestion, you can follow me at that psychology podcast and send me a DM. I love hearing from you. I love hearing what you're going through and thinking about the psychology behind it. So once again, thank you. And we will be back next week with another episode.
从中有所收获。像往常一样，如果有人需要听到这些，请随时分享，传播爱意，并确保在 Apple Podcast、Spotify 或你正在收听的任何地方留下五星评价。我每一条都读。我每一条都看。我每一条都看。它们让我感到无比快乐，我简直不敢相信我们拥有这样一个关爱这些事情的美好社区。非常感谢你们的一路陪伴。如果你有剧集建议，你可以在 That Psychology Podcast 关注我并给我发私信。我喜欢听你们倾诉。我喜欢听你们经历的事情并思考其背后的心理学。再次感谢。我们下周将带着另一集回归。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening. to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《难忘的教训》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你正在与一位深谙此道的有执照的专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《难忘的教训》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
2023年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生育双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我动了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 iHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO%。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。收听《女友们。相信我，宝贝》，在 iHeart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 上，
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者在任何你获取播客的地方。这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。